[Music]
this is star talk
neil degrasse tyson here your personal
astrophysicist and today's show is going
to be things you thought you knew
and old-timers out there know there's
only one person i do that with and
that's chuck chuck nice yes
good to have you man always a pleasure
all right so you're ready to have things
you thought you knew explained yes
because we could do
millions of these
if the criteria is
i don't know
you get you future proofed this
that's right
there will be no shortage of topics my
friend
all right let's let's get to this
i occasionally get questions about the
naming of things in my field
all right and
uh let's take for example the names of
the moon
the planets and their moons
all right
and had you ever wondered how we get
these names
not really but i i mean
i figured somebody looked up and said
i'm going to call it that
because somebody did it right because
for me it had been like you know jupiter
and then jupiter a b c d
you know jupiter one jupiter two jupiter
you know that's because you have no
imagination right there well
that goes
so here we go so the planets
are named
they all have roman
latin names basically okay
and so the name that they're sort of
roman gods
your mercury you know the messenger god
mercury is the fastest moving planet
venus is quite beautiful in the evening
sky
that object got named for venus the
goddess of love and beauty um and then
also in the sky with mars which is red
the color of blood
so the warrior god got named after
that planet or that planet got named
after the warrior god and let's keep
going you have jupiter
um saturn
and those are the plants those are the
plants known to the ancients and then
later would be discovered neptune uranus
and neptune right and
the thing about uranus was both it was
the first
it was the first time
anyone discovered a planet it was
william herschel
back in the in the 1700s and it was like
all the other planets were just known
because they're just in the sky
there's not the person who discovered
them anyone who looked up noticed them
so no one is on record for discovering
mercury venus mars jupiter or saturn
but uranus got discovered and it got
discovered by william herschel
and no one had discovered and therefore
no one had actually named a planet in
modern times well he was a good one
he tried to figure out what to name it
and so
so he did the right thing
okay he
named it after his principal funder
that's what scientists do
wow
artists do the same thing they draw in
the in the in the background the the the
benefactor or whatever you know the
sponsor of the painting just makes the
rich folks feel good right
so
uh so he he named this new star after
king george
okay
all right no that's the king george
that's of the american revolution that
same king george because this is the
late 1800s late 1700s and so that's the
same george that john hancock signed his
big signature
large enough for him to read and say
and hamilton
that same george they're correct oh
that's same king george so who by the
way that king george god could he was a
show stealer
he was good
so i have books from that period so late
1700s early 1800s
where
the the enumeration of planets is very
clear
it's
but we know earth is a planet right so
mercury venus earth
that since copernicus
we knew that earth is a planet as an
object that goes around the sun so we
have mercury venus earth mars jupiter
saturn
george and george george
of course
and george right i have books that list
the planets in that order with those
names and
this was you look back and say what the
what what what that
you know and so so
god we should have left that
i'm telling you right now that would be
the best thing in the world one day
we are going to get to george
with our greatest of technology greatest
of technology we shall one day
set foot upon george
so
so
instead of uranus i'm sorry uranus we
could have went with george's ass
planet
planet george's ass
going to say with a british accent right
exactly indeed
planet jewels ass
i'm sorry i'm so terribly sorry
[Laughter]
i say one day we shall get to george's
arsenal i say my soul cap oh boy one day
we'll get there
so looking forward to being firmly
planted in george's ass
okay stop that's enough okay
oh no
oh no
no no no no no okay okay so it would
take a little while but clearer heads
would prevail
and how do you tell
the discoverer of a planet that he has
to unname it after his king this is very
tentative you know diplomatic
moments here
and so
finally we landed on
uranus
which as from what i have read
is similarly pronounced in
um in both greek and
and and latin in roman um uh it they're
they it's the same word all right so
it's actually a crossover name between
the the roman and the greek okay that's
cool
so that i'll show up later in a minute
so so and after that we get to neptune
that is a you know roman god of the seas
and this sort of thing and then when
pluto was discovered when everyone
believed it was a planet the um pluto is
the god of the underworld and it's roman
so there you have it all right so you
might say well what about the greeks
in the western traditions they were
pretty significant
in what they contributed to all of this
it's not just the romans right romans
are like johnny come lately compared to
the greeks yeah and so we said okay
in our western astronomical traditions
we will honor
not only the romans with planet names we
will honor the greeks
with moon names
uh-huh
okay
there we go so all moons
essentially i there's some exceptions
here i can get to all moons in the solar
system are named after
greek
characters
in the life of the greek
counterpart
to the roman god after whom the planet
is named
gotcha are you with me on that i'm with
you on that so basically you take the
roman
right you find a god
and then you say
okay how's that translate into a greek
god and now we got a name for a moon no
i mean no right no no no no you got you
got you got almost all of it almost so
you got the roman god right asked what
is the greek god counterpart to that
roman god
okay now you look at characters in the
life of the greek god ah gotcha and
those are the names of the moons right
because otherwise you would end up with
just two gods two gods every two
difference of the coin
right yeah but what would be a plan it
wouldn't be a moon and that wouldn't be
right that wouldn't be right you'd be
pissing off some powerful god
so let me give you a list of some of
these moons okay
mercury doesn't have any moons and
neither does venus okay and let's skip
over earth for a moment we'll get back
to earth so what's next
mars
mars has two moons and they're they're
pretty
sorry moons just they're like a dozen
miles across they're not even spherical
oh they're embarrassments they really
are yeah people wondering whether they
were just captured asteroids i was to
say that sounds like a rock that's yeah
it's
that doesn't really sound like the moon
it sounds like a rock that got lost
a wayward rock a wayward rock somebody
lost they rocks
[Laughter]
so so the martian moons are called
phobos and deimos
phobos and deimos yes phobos and deimos
as i have read in the in the in the
greek traditions that's the name of the
each of the two horses
that drives the chariot of mars across
the sky i gotcha phobos and demos yes
which by the way deimos is a really cool
name
demos yeah yeah yeah it totally is
wasted on a rock
it is
a cool level name is
you wasted it on a rock yeah it looks
like an idaho potato it's embarrassing
it's embarrassing but that's all it's
got so
in fact uh one of the uh mars rovers i
forgot which was in the path of a phobos
or demo a phobos eclipse right and so
so it's got a picture of phobos passing
in front of the sun and it's just this
outline of an idaho potato
deep within the full disc of the sun
it's embarrassing yeah that is it was
like it couldn't even cover the whole
sun because it's so little
and it's not even round
so anyway let's keep going so it comes
after mars we get to jupiter
so
uh jupiter its four
brightest moons were named they called
the galilean moons galileo first saw
them through his telescope and then
described them but this is uh let me
remember we have io
ganymede
callisto
and i forgot one
uh callisto gaming io and
don't look at me
i hope you're not helping me
out
you're not waiting for me to jump in
you once you got past ganymede i was
just like oh shoot
how could i forget europa my gosh right
which was the star of the movie 2010. so
uh io callisto ganymede and europa those
are the four biggest
moons
of jupiter's i lost count is
probably near somewhere around 100 moons
or more because every time we get closer
to it we see other tiny little rocks and
what distinguishes a moon from just like
a not moon you know if it's just if it's
orbiting and it's bigger than a dust
particle is it a moon can you be in moon
no matter how little you are this is a
debate and i'm not going to bring that
up here but i'm just going to say those
are the four big ones and those are the
ones that kind of really matter
when you see jupiter through a telescope
there they are okay and there's four of
them and they just they go around
jupiter and galileo when he first saw
them he said oh there's stars
near jupiter and then he looked later on
and he says wait the stars have mooned
moved he called him the gow the the the
the the jupiter stars right and because
why would you think you're discovering a
moon this isn't
you're coming out of out of nowhere and
landing on this information and so he
was able to see that they moved around
they orbited
jupiter oh my gosh that meant that earth
was not the center of all motion look at
that yeah
this this was devastating to people who
wished it were otherwise and the jupiter
stars sounds like a really bad
basketball team
really it does
it's a bad any kind of team right yes
exactly bad soccer team right right so
now let me take you to
uranus
right okay
there was a pact
so as not to piss off the brits who are
very powerful in the late the 1700s
okay all right they're one of the most
powerful forces the world had ever seen
particularly with their naval power okay
so
you're gonna piss off the brits and king
george
what are you gonna do so here's what
they did here's what they did we said
okay we will make an exception of the
greek rule
for the planet uranus
and we will name the moons of uranus
after fictional characters
in the plays of shakespeare
oh
okay i have never
heard this that's ever
so this threw a bone back to the brits
so that they could rest easily that
their king was stripped from the name of
the planet and it had and it became a
roman god council wait a minute a
constellation prize
no
oh
oh god
yeah that was good chuck that was good
i said that
i gotta hand it to you
so
what are some names we have porsche
p-o-r-t-i-a remember porsche from your
shakespeare okay um
a lot of characters from a midsummer's
night dream because that's a very quite
a fantastical
storytelling going on there
among the moon names we have uh umbriel
okay titania
miranda miranda is the lead character in
the tempest uh we have ariel oberon
all right so puck
[ __ ] desdemona all
all these moons have names drawn from
shakespeare
that is i'm that is really stunning
because i mean
i can't believe that that's just
something that everybody should know
because it's so
like almost it feels so random
well it's a little bit of history it's
fun history it's not science so much as
it is just
it's the intersection of science taking
place embedded in our culture yeah
yeah so tonight you go out to the outer
planets by the way pluto the first moon
was discovered around pluto it was named
sharon i think in the greek is karen uh
and karen is the ferry boat driver
who carries your soul across the river
sticks to hades makes sense pluto god of
the underworld
well yeah so but it's hades that's the
so you go to the greek side of that so
make a long story short so this is the
the origin stories of the names of the
moons and in the very later years when
there are many more moons discovered and
you run out of incidental characters in
the life of greek and roman uh gods but
we had many because they led complex and
interesting social lives right so
there's a lot of characters you could
draw from but in modern times a more
inclusive sensibility has descended upon
us and so now there are there are there
are names of of of of gods and other
um uh
other spiritual beings fictional beings
in from other cultures not just greek
and roman
when we fully flesh out all the names of
all the moons so that's that that's uh
that's that's solar system moons 101
chuck oh man that's i'm telling you that
was really cool uh however
from now on i'm sorry i i have to call
uranus
george's ass
chuck we got to take a quick break but
when we come back
guess what i have more explaining to do
excellent
all right when star talk returns
chuck we're back
yes we're going to take a look at the
moon
okay
we looked at the moon a lot lately but
we're not done
all right i'm not finished with it
okay okay can you handle it oh yes
no
[Laughter]
the moon is so mysterious for so many
people for so many reasons and it's
so i mean and it's so romantic yes it's
almost
romantic it's poetic in many respects
yes you know yeah it's in so many
paintings like
you know
yeah and it's it's it's a it's a
fundamental
part of the symbol for islam there's a
crescent moon with christ
with venus in the sky next to it so yeah
the moon is important
and
so a couple of things uh there's an old
saying i know that was venus well okay
it's it's an evening or morning star
right
if it's bright it's generally going to
be venus right but
the
um
it's rare that there's another really
cool star next to it and venus is always
in the sky either with the waning
crescent or the waxing crescent so
typically that's venus in practice it's
venus and by the way it's really cool to
see it when
it's a certain time of night and it
really isn't quite like all the way dark
and it's
called twilight chuck oh use the word
[Laughter]
what do you call it when it's night but
not quite dark
did i just invent something
and you know there's this stuff
around us at all times that you know it
goes in your lungs and you push it out
and that big yellow ball
that gives us light
that i'm so glad you woke up today yes
out of your
40-year coma yes
yes but twilight
venus at twilight is i mean it's and and
you can see it with the naked eye and
it's like it really looks like somebody
turned on the light in the sky yeah yeah
and and a little known fact because
venus orbits the sun
closer than we orbit the sun
okay
venus will never
stray too far away from wherever the sun
is on the sky
it's not going to end up behind us with
the sun in front of us right it's going
to be near the sun
so that's why
you'll typically notice venus just after
sunset
in twilight or just before sunrise
so in evening twilight so dusk
right and then the the poetic other side
of that would be dawn right
cool yeah okay so that's the crescent
moon that's cool so more about the moon
uh all evidence suggests and all
theoretical understanding of the
formation of the moon
helped by the way by rocks we brought
back by the apollo program to study and
look at we get a sense of the origin of
that place you guys remember that that's
why america was great
when we did stuff you know
because we didn't mind our tax dollars
being used to make us the greatest
nation on earth we're just saying
done yet you know
go ahead so we brought back rocks and
we've and we were able to yes analyze
them and realize that the moon doesn't
have much iron in it okay and an object
that size should have much more iron in
it than it does
so how do you make a whole object that
has hardly any iron
so you make it out of a
out of a collision with earth
but it sideswipes earth after earth has
already sunk its iron to its core
right
so when earth was molten
heavy stuff falls to the middle light
stuff floats to the top gotcha compared
to iron rocks are light so all the rocks
floated and the irons sunk iron nickel
gold cadmium all the heavy elements
they're down in the core okay so now
earth has pre-sifted the elements
pre-sifted now you have a
mars-sized impactor that side-swipes the
earth
scattering earth's crust into a ring
around the earth
that mars size impactor keeps going but
the debris mess that it left
continues to orbit the earth
and the slightly larger bits of this
have more gravity than the slightly
smaller bits
so they'll attract more objects and they
get bigger and as they get bigger they
have even more gravity and they get even
bigger and bigger and it's a runaway
exponential growth
the big get bit bigger and the little
ones get
eaten eaten thank you okay
[Laughter]
so
we think over not much time a matter of
months if not only just a few years
earth
had a ring not much unlike not not
unlike saturn and that ring coalesced
into the moon and that moon was 20 times
closer in the sky than it is today oh
wow well that must have looked beautiful
yeah so imagine that just imagine that
or it's 20 times wider imagine like
moonrise it was like that's that's very
star wars you know like
you're standing there in the desert and
you see like you know
a giant
in the sky and you need music to go with
that and that would just totally
complete the scene
so
it turns out
tidal forces
are very sensitive
to distance
very sensitive in other words not
emotionally sensitive but if you change
the distance by a little bit
it'll have a much bigger effect than
you'd otherwise think on the strength of
the tides
okay now i can't get over thinking about
emotionally sensitive title forces
where all of our oceans are just like
where you go
what did i do
what did i do
you said it's you it's not me but i do
did i deserve this why did right
you're just gonna throw away everything
we had
as you slowly drift away
you're so distant
i don't understand
why we don't communicate anymore
you're so distant all we have to do is
talk why are you so distant
there's a space between us
exactly
i don't know how to fill this chasm
between us
i can't do all the work here okay
i'm earth and i can't do all the work
chuck how many hours of therapy have you
been in with your wife
oh god
by the way i'm the one saying that in
therapy not her
[Laughter]
so so so so
mathematically because you can be
mathematically sensitive okay i just
want to broaden your use of the term
sensitivity so
the moon
uh
the the mathematical sensitivity of
tidal forces goes as the cube of the
distance oh sweet okay
so in other words if it just went as the
distance okay
if it was like 20 times closer then the
tides would be like 20 times higher than
they are today
but no
does it go as the distance squared
that would mean the tides would be 20
times 20 higher than than today what's
20 times 20 oh i don't know 400.
don't you pull out a calculator you're
on this show you're going to tell me
what 20 times 20 is let me see hold on
no i'm not doing it
okay you got 400
however
tidal forces go as the cube
of the distance
so the cube is you multiply by itself
three times 20 times 20 that's 400
times another 20.
so 400 times 20 that gets you eight
thousand thousand
so
the tides the oceanic tides on earth
raised by the moon when the moon first
formed
were 8 000 times
higher
wow than they are today
look at that and and and and and look at
that we're trying to get back there with
with global warming that's wonderful
that's a different problem yeah tell me
about it okay so now watch what happens
tides
sloshing
on and off the shores there's friction
between the solid earth and the moving
water
okay and so earth's rotation back then
was actually faster than it is today
all right depending on how far back you
you go you get like an 18 20-hour day
for earth not 24 hours look at that okay
so we have a big moon higher ties faster
rotating earth but the tides are so
ferocious earth is slowing
down man because of it
and in response the moon's orbit is
increasing it is spiraling away from the
earth
cool and it has been doing that ever
since
we still have sloshing of tides on the
shores earth's rotation rate is still
slowing down the moon is still spiraling
away from the earth
but much slower than it once was
why are you killing me softly if you're
gonna leave just leave
i don't understand
oh by the way
we
had tidal influence on the moon
okay the moon at one time rotated like
anybody else in the in the in the solar
system
you see the front side the back side the
left side the right side
but our tidal forces on the moon slowed
its rotation down until we
locked it
we locked the moon's rotation around the
earth that's why i'm leaving
because see
you only see one side of me i'm a
complex person but it seems like you
know when we're together i can only show
you one face
check i
this sounds like a tv series
well we go then why don't you just go
why must you make it so torturous i've
been drifting from you for all these
years
you didn't feel me drifting away i mean
seriously
chuck you can't make
hey you know what this show is called
as the world
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh god that may be the stupidest thing
i've ever done on this show
it's okay okay so so the point is we
tidally locked the moon because we have
stronger tides on the moon than the moon
has on us
and so moon just got locked we slow down
its rotation locked in on it it only
shows one face to us
and the other face we've never seen
until we orbited it with spacecraft the
moon is trying to do the same thing to
us he wants to slow us down so much that
we
only show one face to the moon and the
day that happens we will be in what's
called a double title lock nice
that's there you go that's a nice dance
i like it yeah yeah
so that's so that's what it looks like
chap hey man that that's great
that's not moon lore that's just through
the moon facts hey listen that is that
is awesome i mean
at the moon and the earth
i had locked in the dance so i have to
repeat my one perfect sentence that i've
ever written in my life okay may i
repeat it for you please okay
the rotating planets
orbit the sun
like pure wedding dancers
in a cosmic ballet
choreographed by the forces of gravity
wow
damn
you wrote that
oh
okay all right
chuck we got to end it there okay enough
of them we'll give the moon a rest okay
okay and the earth moon family
exactly well we'll lead them to their
drama
all right chuck we got to take a quick
break but when we come back
some of the explaining i'm going to do
is going to pick up on an earlier
explainer video on constellations but i
only just scratched the surface
way more to come okay stay with us
we're back chuck
yes
we're gonna be talking about
things you thought you knew about the
night sky the constellations
we're gonna pick up where we left off
because i wasn't done with you awesome
let's see if you learned anything from
the first session how many
constellations are there oh god 48.
did i get it
no
chuck
i said
what there as many constellations as
there are keys on a piano oh that's
right 88 i got half of it right
that's not that worse
i got the eight right
[Laughter]
if we're going to the moon and the
engineer says i got half of it right oh
that's the well you got there i mean
you're not going out in space missing
your target you're not coming back i got
half of it right
all right so we said some cool things i
think
of southern hemisphere constellations
known to indigenous people from the
southern hemisphere right would be later
discovered by
europeans and when they named it they
had they were already deep into the
industrial revolution so they started
naming them not after mythical magical
creatures but after like stuff
that was enabling the emergence of a new
kind of brand a new like sexton another
level of civilization there's a sextant
by the way before the sextant was
invented which was
60 degrees of a circle
okay
there's six of those six times 60 is 360
degrees what preceded that was an octant
wow okay that was an eighth of 360
degrees the sky has a sexting and an
octane in it very nice
that feels a little excessive to me all
right
you know be happy with one but no you
want two two out of the 88
constellations are navigational devices
that are kind of the same you know you
never have too many tools i don't know
if that's true okay never
can't open it
so a couple of things um
what's in your mind the most famous
constellation in the southern hemisphere
oh in the southern
god see so what i was going to say but
that's not southern was big dipper but
everybody knows that yeah that's the
north yeah that's the new york times
okay yeah you're southern 8 000 miles
off i know um
no 9 out of 10 people say the southern
cross i was about to say the cross you
did you would not
i really wanted to do that no let me
tell you something i really was about to
say the cross but i was scared to do so
because one night we were sitting out
and you had your
you know top secret uh sky pointer
government issue
and you were and you but there's a cross
in the north too yeah that you would and
so that's why i would i was about to say
across but okay so there's a northern
cross which we love here in the northern
hemisphere and there's a southern cross
but they're really different from each
other
okay the southern cross is
embarrassing compared to the northern
cross oh no okay the southern cross
has
four stars in it
okay it's in the shape of a rhombus
there is no star there's no at the
transept right yeah so you could have
just drawn a rhombus
to remind people from eighth grade
geometry a rhombus is like take a
perfect square sit on it
distort the sides and then you get a
rhombus okay
so it is a stretch
to call the southern cross across
it's a stretch i'm just telling you wow
not only that of all 88 constellations
the southern cross is the smallest
oh your thumbnail at arm's reach
would completely cover all four stars of
the southern cross oh
it is one of the biggest
marketing delusions there ever was and
isn't there crosby stills
uh song crosby net um
that's the only line i know because it
has astronomically gonna say i don't
know this song at all buddy
or they just sing that in the hood
yeah i was gonna say csr that's uh you
know it's a little caucasian i'm just
saying
so this i just want to put put it out
there with the southern cross now
have you ever met people who have
visited the southern hemisphere anywhere
be it africa or australia right and and
they come back and what do they tell you
about the sky
uh i you know i never really got into it
never quite i normally ask them about
the place they were see that's that's
the clubs how's that exactly you know
tell me about the food what did you see
you know only you would be like and so
the night sky yeah i'm sorry
about that nice god
what happens is people visit the
southern hemisphere and they come back
and say the southern hemisphere
atmosphere sky is so beautiful yeah it
is so amazing
oh my gosh
and
and so there's another little delusion
going on there as well
and what is that i don't want to stop
you from liking the southern hemisphere
sky better than the north
uh
i have no problems with that
but there are forces operating that
contaminate your data
okay okay do you know how much of
earth's land is in the southern
hemisphere
um i would say not a lot not a lot about
i mean when you look at africa it's like
that's most of it yes okay about 15
of earth's land mass is south of the
equator
okay that's also about 15 of earth's
population
okay
so hardly anybody lives in the southern
hemisphere right
so there's hardly any city lights hardly
any light pollution air pollution all
the things that subtract away from our
experience embracing the sky in the
north does not
block your view in the south so people
think the actual sky is better
because they can see it better
wow
so
i'm telling you
that the north has all the coolest
constellations
all right you know with the big dipper
and you know and the little dipper and
the you know and
and and cassiopeia some constellations
straddle the north and the south or ryan
is half in the north and half in the
south but when we look at him he's right
side up you want to see orion in the
southern hemisphere he's upside down
that there's there's there's no excuse
for that
so i'm just i'm a northern chauvinist
here but i think i have good reason for
it
yeah but the the problem is we can't see
it
i mean you can be as hot as you want
you know but if you're walking around in
a burlap sack nobody's gonna know nobody
knows how hot you are
wow so yeah so this is an interesting
fact about it
now here's a so the northern cross is
much bigger than the southern cross and
there's a star in the transept for it
right okay it's called and that's an
asterism
an asterism is a set of stars
that is the more interesting subset of
all the stars that comprise the
constellation sweet so
the northern cross is cygnus the swan
the constellation which is not only
those stars in the cross but there are
other stars where you can imagine wings
and it's flying long neck
neck swan along the milky way so it's a
beautiful
thought that there's a swan doing this
but it's bluntly across
now
last thing i'll tell you there's more
but i just want to sort of put it out
there
um
many of the star star constellations are
all greek and some latter day
technologically related ones but some of
the earliest navigators were the arabs
okay the entire arabian peninsula all
those folks there are very few clouds
because it's desert and so you saw the
night sky and you want to get around
there's no monuments there's no gps
there are no mile markers how are you
going to get around
so they pioneered astrolabes which was
their version of the european sextant
okay and the octet the astrolabe they
did it first and and it's beautiful
works of art with rotating dials and you
hold it up and you can get the angle and
their tables and charts it's
magnificent all etched in brass
beautiful we have a collection at the
american museum of natural history but
one of the largest collections in the
world is at the adler planetarium and
astronomy museum in chicago
they have one of the largest collections
of astrolabes in the world anyhow point
is
as an homage to
the arabic role in navigating the sky
two-thirds of all stars in the sky that
have names
have arabic names oh wow
this is part of the sort of
inclusiveness of my field
where if you contributed to it we're not
going to forget you
and and by the way in the constellation
libra
this scales
um
the two brightest stars in that
constellation are arabic
names one of them is zubin el janubi and
the other is zubin s shamali
okay those are the two longest star
names of all name stars in the sky and
what is the abbreviation for
pound
lbs lb you know what lb stands for
uh
uh
no i don't
libra
the scales it just gets worse
[Laughter]
first you go from pounds to lb right
right
and lb is a short for libra
right the measurement of things that's
so cool i chuck we gotta call it quits
okay have you had enough things you
thought you knew explained to you i
never get enough of explaining okay
there's things i thought i knew and i'm
like i thought i knew but i didn't know
yeah and the stuff you didn't know that
you thought you knew it exactly that
counts i didn't know i thought i knew
this and now i know that i do
and then there's some stuff that i
didn't want to know at all
and i still know it now
occasionally you have to know stuff that
you didn't want to know at all
that happens in life that's right and
that'll happen here on things you
thought you knew
always good to have you chuck
there's been star talk of things you
thought you knew edition neil degrasse
tyson here
[Music]
okay bye bye do you know what the name
of our moon is
oh
no the moon how did that happen yeah
yeah everybody gets these great names
and we and we have
moon moon no no it has a name it's
called luna
oh that makes sense and and and that's
funny because in certain languages they
call it luna yeah luna and earth has a
name
okay
earth it's called terra
oh yeah
okay and we're called terrans in most
sci-fi films
yes we are yes we are called terrance
and the sun has a name
okay
it's called soul sol
nice yeah so if you just latinized
everything we have salt terra and we
have luna you got all the planets and
everybody's one happy family of cultural
expression and diversity
awesome